foreign
is a chlorinated triazine systemic
herbicide that is used to selectively
control annual grasses and broadleaf
weeds before they emerge pesticide
products containing after seen are
registered for use on several
agricultural crops with the highest use
on field corn sweet corn sorghum and
sugar cane additionally atrazine
products are registered for use on wheat
macadamia nuts and guava as well as
non-agricultural uses such as nursery
and ornamental and Turf epa's oversight
of atrocene is dynamic and includes
periodic reevaluation through the
registration review process over the
years EPA has consulted with the fifra
scientific advisory panel on a variety
of atrocene topics well we'll come back
to that at the end of this little review
of what some of the science the
so-called basic science as opposed to
applied science that is the science that
is simply trying to understand what is
true as opposed to being driven to uh
you know develop a product or or solve a
problem that we know ourselves to have
as humans some of the basic science
um
husband for a long time warning of the
dangers of atrocene and in fact enough
so that we actually talked about it and
we recently responded to a question in
the Q a about this but we actually
talked about this briefly in our book
undergatherer's guide at the 21st
century I'm going to read this
um just one paragraph from this is at
the end of most of the chapters in in
our book uh which came out in 2021 we
have what we call the corrective lens so
given the subject of the chapter in this
case it's sex and gender uh what might
you do uh to help you resolve whatever
issues you might have uh that stem from
a hyper novel modern environment and and
get yourself back into a state that is
healthier and more productive so one of
our corrective lens points uh finishing
the sex and gender chapter in
hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century is
um
keep contaminants away from fetuses and
children and several species of frogs
there is an established relationship
between exposure to Common environmental
contaminants like atrazine and herbicide
an increase in hermaphroditic
individuals while sex determination in
frogs is different than in humans we
will not be surprised if it turns out
that some of the modern confusion around
sex and gender ends up attributable to
widespread endocrine disruptors in our
environment
and we have a footnote there an endnote
um
pointing to two research papers
published in uh
let's see 2002 and 1998 which I'm going
to talk about a little bit uh here uh
which is one of the research papers is
from the excellent Tyrone Hayes uh a
researcher out of I think Berkeley if I
remember correctly who I was lucky
enough to see at a conference sometime
around then late 90s early Yachts
um he's an excellent scientist and also
a very Dynamic speaker which always
helps and
um
he was already on this this drum beat
back in 2000 2002. so here's uh the
paper that we
uh referenced in hunter-gatherer's guide
for Hayes at all uh indeed he was at
Berkeley at least at the time this is
published in
um pns proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences
which for those not in the know if if
you care you can you can tell that I
figured that because it was communicated
by in this case David wake you have to
be a member of the National Academy of
Sciences to publish in proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences or
um be be recommended by someone who is
and they have a limited number of
recommendations they can make per year I
don't remember what it is
um but this the title of this paper
published in 2002 is hermaphroditic
demasculinized frogs after exposure to
the herbicide atrazine at low
ecologically relevant doses
and the paper is excellent I'm not going
to walk us through this in depth there
are a number of papers I just want to to
point to here
um but that title
says a lot of it right there
atrocene which we've already talked
about what the EPA says it is and it's
on a majority of corn crops and many
wheat crops and sugar cane as well not
allowed to be on on crops that are
certified organic but it spreads easily
as we shall learn through the air
through um through the soil
and through water and what we have is
after exposure to atracine at what
they're calling low ecologically
relevant doses which is to say we had
been told that you needed High exposure
in order for it to make any difference
frogs are ending up hermaphroditic and
demasculinized after such exposure
now as we say in hunter-gatherer's guide
the mechanisms of sex determination and
frogs are different from that in in
humans uh but they too are vertebrates
with two and only two Sexes and um while
uh while the mechanism by which what sex
an individual frog is is not well in
some frogs it actually is but it's a
different origin of chromosomal sex
determination in some cases and it's a
environmental sex determination and
others
um
still it is
logical to imagine that if other
vertebrates are experiencing
reproductive
difficulties and endocrinological
disruption after exposure to low doses
of atracine that we too should be
concerned about the effects on other
vertebrates
so I would just point out that there is
a question here about the presumption of
safety versus harm and especially when
you are dealing with a pesticide you're
dealing with something that is
biologically active enough to disrupt an
organism that is a threat to a crop and
what one hopes for of course is
something that disrupts a mechanism that
is so unique to the pest that it is not
disruptive of other things in the
environment and human health and
Physiology but it's very hard to do that
because biology is you know we are all
related and biology is conservative it
builds on mechanisms
that unite us and of course there are
mechanisms that evolve after are split
from a different clade
and you might occasionally happen on one
of these things but one should basically
assume that something uh effective
enough at disrupting pests has a
likelihood of interacting with human
physiology in ways that are
unpredictable and may take a very long
time to discover if you have a system
that is immune to perverse incentives
looking for the evidence that it either
does or does not cause such a disruption
yes uh and indeed although the mechanism
of sex determination is separately
evolved in frogs and in humans the
pathways of masculinization and
feminization and the hormones that are
relevant in those Pathways everything
from the androgens including
testosterone Anderson diione to the
estrogens and progesterone oxytocin uh
the stero the other steroid hormones all
of these things well predate
the last time that frogs and humans had
a most recent I'm an ancestor so there's
plenty that is older than the most
recent common ancestor of frogs and
humans even though the particular ways
that it is determined whether
individuals become male or female
is are different let me just show you
show everyone a few more papers here uh
the very following the next year uh we
have Hayes again the haze lab out of
Berkeley
um atrazine-induced hermaphroditism at
0.1 parts per billion in American
leopard frogs ranipipians leopard
leopard laboratory and field evidence
um
and just the beginning of the abstract
here atrocene is the most commonly used
herbicide in the United States and
probably the world after seeing
contamination is widespread and can be
present in excess of one parts per
billion even in precipitation and in
areas where it is not used
in the current study we showed that
after scene exposure at greater that
than 0.1 parts per billion resulted in
[__] gonadal development that is
gonadal dysgenesis and testicular
ogenesis hermaphroditism in leopard
frogs and slower developing males even
experienced oocyte growth fidelogenesis
okay so that is
um that is reproductive chaos induced by
atraxine at very very low levels in the
environment even in places where it has
never been applied in leopard frogs okay
uh that's a that's a such an important
and non-intuitive point is that the
degree to which these things atomize
into the world and exist at very low
levels that is to say you might not
detect them but that doesn't mean that a
biological system will not be disrupted
by them because these biological systems
are very sensitive to things that are
designed to be disruptive in insects
exactly
exactly so the other paper that we
referenced in um
in hunter-gatherer's guide and just like
really a side comment about this is
reader at all from
yeah this was 1998 a few years earlier
forms and prevalence of intersexuality
and effective environmental contaminants
on sexuality in cricket frogs Acres
crepitans
uh so this is a different species indeed
a different family of frogs these are
Highlands these are tree frogs and uh
and just here's uh
uh here's one true thing they say the
process of sex determination and the
influences on sex determination are not
understood for this species we are
unaware of any reports that Acres
crepitans experiences intersexuality or
undergoes a sex reversal as a normal
part of any of its life stages whereas
they are finding and they're
specifically looking at pcbs and pcdfs
um but uh they're they're finding
intersexuality General again
reproductive chaos and endocrine
disruption as a result of exposure in
very low amounts
so I want to unpack a little bit of the
expectation here The evolutionary
expectation
you've got
plants right a uh a biological clade
that has an insect problem because
plants uh are autotrophs they take
sunlight and they turn
the carbon in the atmosphere into
Structural Materials
insects don't do this so insects have to
eat something many of them eat plants
right it's one of the go-to things and
in order to eat plants insects have to
be able to withstand the poisons that
plants introduce in order to prevent
insects from eating them so in the
second called secondary compounds that
plants put into themselves in order
specifically to not be eaten right so
secondary compound if you're a biologist
and you find a compound inside of a
given plant and that compound doesn't do
anything in the plant it's not part of
photosynthesis or respiration if it's
just existing there without obvious
explanation the explanation tends to be
that it is a poison designed to disrupt
the physiology of herbivores especially
insects in order to reduce the the
amount of material lost to these
parasites
so insects and plants have been involved
in an arms race over this very thing
since long before the revertebrates
I think that's fair statement yes yes so
the point is you should expect
plants to create very uh effective
toxins and insects to be very resistant
to them which is why it is hard to deal
with pests with insecticides because a
it's hard to come up with anything that
overcomes the amazing architecture that
insects have devised to detoxify this
stuff and if you do they have an
evolutionary preparedness to evolve past
the whatever defense you have deployed
and so those pathogens will tend to
evolve out from under uh the The Killing
effects of antibiotics
insects will if possible find a way to
evolve out from under the killing
effects of herbicides right so what you
tend to end up doing if you come up with
an herbicide that actually works enough
to be useful it tends to be extremely
toxic and highly complex enough to
defeat this system in insects so at the
point you've discovered something good
enough to be an insecticide you ought to
be really worried about the safety of
this stuff around other bile logical
organisms well but luckily insects are
an entirely different evolution of life
and therefore what affects them doesn't
affect us
would that were true that that were true
which actually you know there's an echo
in here of
um of Jordan Peterson's uh often
misunderstood point about lobsters his
point is you've got a very ancient
system that deals with serotonin that
this is a conserved molecular
intermediary in a process that is old
enough to go back you know so that we
find it in lobsters and in this case
serotonin turns out to be one of the the
oldest hormones that we know and in fact
the most recent common ancestor of
lobsters and humans both had serotonin
right so in any case insecticides are
heart chemical insecticides are hard to
produce why because
the world has been engaged in an arms
race between plants and insects forever
and that arms race prepares the insects
very well so yes we have some ability to
do stuff in a lab that plants have a
hard time doing but the ability to do
something worth doing that is safe for
other creatures is pretty minimal and
you know again bad enough if you have
regulatory agencies that are completely
free to discover the harm and forbid the
use of stuff that's actually bad for
people and the environment if you have
captured entities then you're just at
the mercy of companies who will make
billions of dollars producing these
molecules that are not safe for people
because they do work on crops and that's
where we're going to find ourselves yeah
let's talk about the capture after we
finish talking about the uh the science
sure
um so this still from this reader at all
paper from 1998. so and I include these
older papers in part because that's what
we cited but also to indicate for how
long research has been going on that is
sending up the signal that says beware
these are not as safe as we are being
told they are right so a couple more uh
pieces from the reader at all 1998 paper
um uh which I have apparently subtitled
they're making the frogs militant ah I
see on my screen here for those who are
carefully reading
um sex ratios of cricket frog shortly
after metamorphosis strongly favor
females as was the case at the control
sites in study B however at the sites
contaminated by pcbs and pcdfs there was
a striking sex ratio reversal in
juvenile Cricket frogs resulting in a
high number of males so sex ratio
reversal is a stunning result as
um that apparently is emerging um
after exposure to some of these
environmental contaminants and then
feminization due to estrogenic and or
anti-androgenic contaminants has been
well documented in many species of
vertebrates
and they've got this is again from 1998
so these are all going to be older than
1998 references and I'm going to scroll
down and show you show us those various
congeners that's just various engineers
and mixtures of pcbs pcdfs and pcdds
possess a spectrum of estrogenic
anti-estrogenic and anti-androgenic
effects
we knew a lot of this a long time ago
okay so these references and this is
only a tiny bit of the references that
are out there but this very
article sites include number five
ddt-induced feminization of Gull embryos
so that's from 1981 DDT of course
famously is off the market but most of
these things aren't off the market in
the U.S it is still used elsewhere yeah
20.
environmentally persistent alkyl
phenolic compounds are estrogenic that's
from 1994.
a synergistic activation of estrogen
receptor with combinations of
environmental chemicals from 1996
reference 22 we have developmental
abnormalities of the gonad and abnormal
sex hormone concentrations and juvenile
alligators from contaminated and control
lakes in Florida from 1994. reference 23
published in nature persistent DDT
metabolite ppde is a potent Androgen
receptor Agonist
and then we have just just a few more
and this is again not exhaustive from
1979 estrogenic properties of DDT and
its analogs
we have factors affecting mammary tumor
incidents in Chlor triazine treated
female rats hormonal properties dosage
and animal strain
we have an ecological study of the
cricket frog 1984
um diethyl stilbustrol Associated
defects and mirin genital tract
development that's met that's mice so
now we're now we're talking actually
about mammals uh from 1985 and in utero
and lactational exposure of male rats to
one of these toxins and
um I think and that paper is this and uh
it you know effects on spermatogenesis
and reproductive capability
so many people will have heard
tangentially or not so tangentially
about lowering T levels lowering
fertility in men across the world where
well you know one of the sets of
explanatory factors is is right here
so
a couple more pieces of
sort of expected oh go ahead and that
research was published in 1992. 92. yeah
as you say we've known about this for a
very long time very long time
researchers have been doing the research
that shows that
um atrocene and several other chemicals
of which I have talked about a few here
um definitely disrupt reproduction and
endocrine systems in amphibians at least
and furthermore there's a lot of
research about the Persistence of for
instance atrazine in uh Soil and Water
here we have
um it's a little bit bigger than you can
show my screen here Zach
uh published in 2011. we have a
jablenowski at all paper called still
present after all these years
persistence plus potential toxicity
raised questions about the use of
atrazine
the abstract reads as one of the world's
most heavily applied herbicides atrazine
is still a matter of controversy since
it is regularly found in ground and
drinking water as well as in seawater
and the ice of remote areas it has
become the subject continuous concern
due to its potential endocrine and
carcinogenic activity
current findings prove long-held
suspicions of this compound persist for
decades in soil
due to the high amount applied annually
all over the world the soil burden of
this compound is considered to be
tremendous representing a potential
long-term threat to the environment the
Persistence of chemicals such as
atrazine has long been underestimated do
we need to reconsider the environmental
risk so this paper again is published 12
years ago
and here are just a few more things from
it
additionally recent evidence of
endocrine disruption activity of
atrocene itself and environmentally
relevant concentrations is cause for
serious concerns in terms of a
precautionary approach we believe that
the further use of atrazine should be
halted or greatly curtailed
atracine and its metabolites can persist
in water and soil for decades even more
than 18 years after it was banned in
Germany atrazine Remains the most
abundant pesticide in groundwater
samples I think I have one more oh no
that's it oh
um yeah that's that's it for for that
paper so
we know it's disrupting endocrine
systems and other vertebrates we know it
persists for decades after it has
stopped being used in the soil and is
found in seawater in remote ice so it is
it is everywhere and even in for
instance Europe which banned it a number
of years ago they still see it in their
soil
[Music]